what would life be like if we willingly
gave away our privacy what would our
world look like if there were no
government only corporations who would
save us from our oppressors from
ourselves could a young girl without any
superpowers be a catalyst for change
these are questions you may ask
yourselves and these are the question
that inspired us as we set out to bring
me research to new generation of gamers
welcome to Mirror's Edge catalyst this
is a revolutionary action-adventure game
where you will experience the origin
story of our heroine faith from a
careless young woman to a fierce heroine
who opens the eyes of an entire city
she's not your usual video game hero and
because this is a truly immersive
first-person experience you're not just
watching the events unfold in front of
you you are faith she is graceful
elegant and as efficient as she is
powerful she doesn't need any guns faith
combines her momentum martial arts
combat and her mastery of the
environments this environment is the
city of glass built on the latest
version of our frostbite engine it's
beautiful and stylized but behind the
beautiful facade like the dark truth the
city is ruled by the corporations led by
this man Gabriel Kruger there is no
individual freedom there is no privacy
you will uncover these secrets as you
explore the city on your terms there's
plenty for you to do and we're giving
you the freedom of choice there are
story missions activities like time
trials and races and
mental puzzles most importantly there
are no levels there are no loading
screens you are truly free roaming fluid
movements and combat in first-person
running free in a beautiful massive city
experiencing the rise of faith this is
her origin story and for those of you
here at e3 you can come by and play for
yourself at the EA booth here's the
world premiere of Mirror's Edge catalyst
captured fully an engine coming February
23rd 2016 every new day holds a promise
you can waste it or spend it advancing
yourself a productive employee is a
happy employee rise the high caste level
your possibilities are infinite
personal freedom comes at a price
wary of policy breakers in our midst
[Music]
faith are you there gotta run with
Krueger but I got something for it
[Music]
stop her
I don't like what's coming faith this
city is changing and not for the better
unless of course we stop it come on girl
see the saw
[Music]
[Applause]